[Musica]
[Applauso]
oggi vi parla amore
dell'amore di coppia che ci aiuta a
crescere insieme e non ci fa avere paura
dei sentimenti un noto proverbio dice
che tra il dire e il fare c'è di mezzo
il mare
e se invece del mare
nel mezzo ci fosse provare per questo vi
racconterò cosa ho scoperto in questi 35
anni di lavoro clinico con le coppie e
poi deciderete voi cosa provare
ma come è cambiata la coppia che
incontrò in tutti questi decenni
diciamo che in linea di massima dall 85
al 95
la coppia portava soprattutto
problematiche relative all'educazione
dei figli e alla gestione delle famiglie
d'origine che resta pur sempre un
evergreen però il punto era quello di
tenere unita la famiglia a tutti i costi
nella buona e nella cattiva sorte anche
a scapito della felicità dei partner
dal 95 al 2005 sempre in linea di
massima il riflettore si è spostato
sulla necessità di una realizzazione
personale e professionale dell'individuo
realizzarsi e giusto per carità ma
questo ha messo ancora sullo sfondo la
coppia che novella cenerentola è
diventata ancora più fragile ed
evanescente invece negli ultimi 15 anni
sotto lo stress le pressioni lavorative
la necessità di essere performanti un po
su tutti i piani la formazione
soprattutto la durata della coppia è
diventata ancora più difficoltosa
come ha osservato bauman attualmente
siamo un po tutti combattuti siamo
ambivalenti tra il desiderio di
sicurezza che si può ottenere attraverso
una relazione stabile e il desiderio di
libertà che si ottiene meglio rimanendo
da soli a inseguire la propria felicità
soprattutto le generazioni che sono
uscite dalla famiglia senza necessità
del matrimonio oppure le persone che
hanno già avuto una relazione
sentimentale
raggiungono una sorta di equilibrio che
difficilmente
mettono in discussione quando arriva
all'orizzonte un amore
nei casi estremi proprio di rifiuto
dell'amore ghezzani ha parlato di
anoressia sentimentale e invece quelli
che vogliono provare a
mettersi in gioco in coppia e devono
essere proprio degli acrobati perché
devono mettere insieme gli interessi
di entrambi magari gestire due case due
gruppi di amici ea volte anche due diete
differenti e poi ultimo ma non ultimo
devono tenere acceso il desiderio
sessuale
cosa non semplice se pensiamo che le
ultime ricerche ci dicono che quattro
coppie su dieci coppie stabili definite
coppie bianche
rinunciano completamente alla sessualità
e forse vi stupirà sapere che sono
soprattutto gli uomini ad accampare il
famoso mal di testa
in questo in questo aggiungiamo un
ultimo ostacolo che in questo periodo di
narcisismo imperante
tutto ci porta ad evitare ciò che può
far soffrire ma anche solo che può
qualcosa che può comportare l'odore del
fallimento per cui si evita di parlarsi
per non entrare in conflitto si
bypassano gli attriti per non fare la
fatica di scioglierli si evitano i
sacrifici scegliendo strada e anche più
semplici e soprattutto si sopprimono i
sentimenti per la paura di soffrire
ma la soluzione forse non è né stare
sempre soli e neanche cambiare
continuamente partner perché se non
abbiamo compreso cosa non ha funzionato
dentro di noi ripeteremo lo schema
all'infinito
e poi se ci pensiamo per nessuna
relazione c'è una garanzia e smettere di
amare per paura di essere feriti traditi
da luz delusi
sarebbe un po come smettere di mangiare
perché sappiamo che dopo qualche ora
avremo ancora fame oppure non vivere
perché tanto sappiamo di dover morire
invece è proprio oggi che i sentimenti
sono messi sullo sfondo con uno scomodo
intralcio
la coppia può essere proprio una grande
palestra per la crescita emotiva di
entrambi i partner
non importa chi dei due che accade in
crisi per primo basta che entrambi lo
vogliano desiderino di affrontare la
sofferenza invece di evitarla per uscire
dallo stallo per addentrarci nella vita
delle coppie ho preparato per voi 4
sintetici affreschi delle coppie che ho
incontrato più frequentemente e chissà
se vi riconoscerete
i compatibili in questo incastro
perfetto è come aver trovato proprio
l'altra metà della mela
1 e l'adulto serioso l'altro il bambino
giocoso uno vuole sempre insegnare e
l'altro vuole sempre imparare uno
combina sempre guai e l'altro
immancabilmente glieli risolve questi
questi ganci
sono collegati a aspetti dell'infanzia
di entrambi i partner
ma cosa succede se uno se se qualcuno
volesse cambiare ruolo
ad esempio se chi combina sempre guai
volesse cominciare a risolvere da solo è
la coppia andrebbe in crisi perché
cambiare il ruolo sarebbe quasi come
perdere identità
i pacifisti
questi partner sono invece coalizzati
contro un mondo che ritengono cattivo e
foriero di tensioni per cui anche se
hanno bisogno di aiuto piuttosto
implodono ma non chiedo un aiuto la
paura è che un attrito anche molto
piccolo possa incrinare o addirittura
rompere la relazione
per questo i partner sminuiscono negano
tutto ciò che può creare tensione e
anche le famiglie d'origine gli amici se
creano tensione vengono pian piano
allontanati
solo che tutta questa polvere messa
sotto al tappeto
da una parte assicura la stabilità però
impedisce al nuovo di entrare nella
relazione e soprattutto non permette
alle crisi di essere utilizzate come
leve per il cambiamento
gli esploratori il mondo è un luogo
pieno di cose piacevoli da fare
viaggiare uscire andare e venire e anche
lo stimolo del nostro tempo ci spinge a
consumare esperienze senza soffermarci
troppo sulle interiorità della coppia e
la ricerca del piacere in queste in
queste coppie all'inizio è molto
entusiasmante solo che col tempo
diventa quasi spasmodica e non da mai
veramente la soddisfazione
questi partner tendono dividono diciamo
loro interessi con gruppi di persone e
non esitano a trovare amici più giovani
man mano che la loro età avanza quindi
splendidi compagni di avventura molto
difficilmente si mettono a nudo null
altro e quindi coltivano poco l'intimità
della coppia
la coppia imprenditori queste ultime due
sono coppie più moderne e qui è come
incontrare qualcuno che come noi
condivida il desiderio di sacrificarsi
per creare casa per fare carriera per
per avere dei figli per cui il tempo è
tutto programmato sia il tempo
quotidiano che il tempo negli anni è
programmato sin nei minimi dettagli
questa
apparente diciamo sicurezza in realtà è
schematicità è proprio uno schema molto
ferreo che impedisce di accedere a tutto
il bello a tutta l'imperfezione umana
queste se questa situazione delle coppie
era già abbastanza complessa poi è
arrivata la pandemia
immaginate che fatica hanno fatto gli
esploratori a non poter più trovare
all'esterno la fonte del loro piacere ea
trovarsi bloccati in casa oppure gli
imprenditori che hanno dovuto congelare
per un tempo indeterminato i loro
progetti o magari pacifisti che già
spaventati degli attriti del mondo dopo
il lockdown hanno fatto più fatica ad
inserirsi per che hanno vissuto
l'esterno come ancora più pericoloso
mi piacerebbe sapere se vi siete
riconosciuti almeno in alcuni tratti sì
perché in effetti
per creare una coppia sana c'è qualcosa
da imparare da ognuna di queste coppie
all'inizio è importante riuscire a
creare un incastro perfetto avere dei
ruoli che siano ben incastrati come
sanno fare compatibili
e altresì fondamentale
saper abbassare la tensione quando
eccessiva come sanno fare i pacifisti
durante tutta la relazione è
importantissimo mantenere un tempo di
divertimento un tempo leggero così come
a un certo punto inevitabile
programmare il futuro avere dei progetti
fare qualcosa insieme
quindi che cos'è che non non funziona
come ha teorizzato luigi baldascini è la
fissità in una sola di queste
configurazioni che alla lunga ci fa star
male
ci fa sentire
insoddisfatti anche della vita di coppia
al contrario la mobilità tra tutte
queste configurazioni ci aiuta a
diventare persone di spessore
persone felici di essere in coppia
quindi una coppia sana è una coppia
elastica e mobile e per questo ho
pensato di chiamarli i trapezisti
i trapezisti
sono consapevoli del rischio di cadere
che hanno ogni giorno ma non vengono
annientati da questa paura perché sanno
di poter godere di una rete di
protezione costituita dalle altre
relazioni significative
non si aggrappano all'altro ma
volteggiano sicuri nell'aria certi della
presa che si scambieranno al momento
giusto
negli anni migliora l'autostima di
ciascuno perché grazie all'amore
reciproco
migliora l'amore per se e poi sono
acrobati che ne vedono veramente tante
di tutti i colori sono molto resilienti
e insieme si aiutano ad aumentare il
senso di fiducia nei confronti della
vita
in maniera
del tutto soggettiva
ho individuato cinque ingredienti che
non devono mancare a due partner che
aspirino a diventare trapezisti
vediamoli insieme
il primo prezioso ingrediente e la
creatività i trapezisti
considerano la coppia un'opera d'arte
viva e quindi è sempre migliorabile e
imperfetta ma questo ne aumenta la
bellezza per cui dedicano cure
creatività al legame e non dimenticano
mai la potenzialità che avevano intuito
all'inizio del loro incontro
l'attenzione costante sappiamo bene che
all'inizio di una relazione la nostra
attenzione verso il partner è al massimo
poi la quotidianità porta un certo
rilassamento ad esempio proprio nella
vita sessuale che scolorisce finisce un
po sullo sfondo se non ci sono due
persone attente a prendersi cura
per questo i trapezisti non danno mai
l'altro per scontato e sono sempre grati
quando i loro corpi si intrecciano in
aria
l'amicizia l'amicizia è alla base delle
coppie che superano la prova del tempo
perché e come sapere di poter sempre
contare su qualcuno però un amico un
alleato può essere anche molto diverso
da noi
e siccome il trapezista si fida del suo
alleato invece di difendersi dalla
diversità né a cella accetta e si fa a
contaminare
solitudine come nutrimento
quando il partner non ci coinvolge in
tutte le sue cose ci possiamo sentire
esclusi invece il kun trapezista ha
fiducia dei momenti di assenza del
partner e li utilizza per allenarsi e
per nutrirsi di ingredienti che poi
riporterà in maniera come in un circolo
virtuoso con gioia all'interno della
coppia
ultimo ma non ultimo essere sponsor
della felicità dell'altro un buon
trapezista sostiene il partner nei
cambiamenti personali perché non ha
paura di perderlo
questo elemento a volte scatta
inconsapevolmente noi non ci rendiamo
conto di ostacolare l'altro nella sua
felicità però diciamo che essere sponsor
della felicità dell'altro e forse il
parametro più difficile però è
fondamentale per una vita di coppia
soddisfacente
quindi la coppia oggi è in crisi tutte
le statistiche del sono contro non ci
sono garanzie per la sua durata e
abbiamo paura di essere feriti traditi
da lui delusi ma proviamo a correre il
rischio di amare e di essere amati
di investire in una relazione
sentimentale
perché non c'è modo migliore di evolvere
che farlo in una coppia di abili
trapezisti grazie
[Applauso]